I am off the view that there must in
this case be a discretionary life
sentence and that is the sentence I
impose upon you there will be a sentence
of custody for life
the risks around you albeit as a young
man are clear and concerning
the way in which you say some things to
professionals and yet say the contrary
to others means that there is my
judgment no clear picture of when those
risks May abate
that position supports my decision as to
dangerousness leading to custody for
life
you have pleaded guilty your plea
warrants a reduction in a sentence would
otherwise have been passed
having reflected on the submissions made
this morning the appropriate reduction
in your cases is one-third
having considered what would otherwise
be the appropriate categorization as
case and the impact of the aggravating
and mitigating features including age
and maturity the appropriate sentence
and minimum term as I indicate would be
one of nine years custody allowing for
your plea a minimum term of six years as
there is now no early release for
terrorist offenders that minimum term is
the same as what this used to be called
the determinant term the days on Ramon
which I'm told number 367 days will
count towards that sentence and so the
sentence of this chord is one of custody
for life with a minimum of six years
less 360 seven days
what that means is this that before you
will be first considered for parole
there will be a period of six years less
367 days if the information which I've
been provided as the days on remand
proved to be inaccurate then the
prosecution or defense must notify the
court so that the case can be re-listed
to correct that calculation as soon as
possible and in any event within 56 days
when it comes to the minimum term that
you will serve I make plain that I am
not ordering that you are to be released
at the end of it whether you'll be
released or not at that stage or at any
later stage will be a matter for the
parole board to consider only when the
minimum term has been served can the
parole will decide whether it is safe to
release you or not
if the board does release you you remain
on license and liable to recall for the
rest of your life
if the statutory surcharge applies to
your case then the appropriate orders
can be drawn up I order the forfeiture
under section 23 of the charismat 2000
of four items rjb1 a mobile phone
rjb2 a laptop rjb 23 tactical combat
plugs and rjb20 tactical combat goggles
you will be subject to notification
requirements as set out in the
counterterrorism act 2008.
you may go down